I'm Brad Paisley and my favorite movie
is It's a Wonderful Life
I grew up in Glendale West Virginia and
the nearest movie theater was in Ohio
across the Ohio River and to where I saw
everything I mean I you know everything
from the time I was a young kid to when
I left for Nashville at 20 years old
there is a massive similarity between
country songs and movies maybe more so
than any other art form country songs
when done in a story form are the
closest thing to a Hollywood script
you'll find my favorite movie of all
time is It's a Wonderful Life and I've
studied it a little bit of read about it
quite a bit and it's an interesting
thing to think about how taken for
granted that movie was in its day much
later when it was I think being shown
every Christmas and became this thing
that people realized was just absolutely
perfect you really had a wonderful life
well Jimmy Stewart was incapable of a
bad performance from what I've seen he
was just one of those rare gifts to
cinema like Andy Griffith was -
television like BB King was - the Blues
that they just they it's like okay
that's how you do it George Bailey grabs
the the knob off of the top of the
staircase and the thing that infuriated
him we all have that in our house we
have that thing that's like oh you've
got to be kidding it for me it's the
it's the hot-water heater that keeps
going out but I think about it if you
got stuck somewhere you know in a
life-threatening situation or something
well that made you appreciate your home
and your family in your life you would
miss that hot-water heater that doesn't
work the same way the George Bailey
walks up and grabs that no that's the
power of movies they remind us of
something in our lives whether it's on
the nose or not - my big brother George
the richest man in town
hang on it watch this I'm Brad Paisley
and I love movies
you